The ultimate sweetest thing you can do for someone...
...is to present them with a hearty breakfast in bed.
Imagine how happy your partner will be...
...if you whip up a plate of heart-shaped red velvet cakes,...
...waffles, cookies and toast when he or she wakes up.
Well, the pandemic has been quite long...
...and we are pretty sure that there are a lot of upgrades...
...that you might want to do to your room or your house.
Bring in some paint cans, put out some music or the stereo...
...and have a great bonding time with your partner....
...as you both work on your ideas together.
We know that you all love to go out...
...and catch a romantic comedy on the screens on this day...
...but hey, pandemic alert.
But how about making your own home theater?
You can put out some popcorn, prop up some cushions...